the advice I would give to anyone not to
sound too much like a certified
financial planner is to diversify as
much as possible I mean the old days you
could be a drummer and make a great
living you know because you'd go on tour
with a band or you play sessions and
those days have kind of come to an end
you know just the money just isn't there
so my advice to anyone would be to
diversify and if you're a musician learn
how to DJ learn how to play live learn
how to produce other artists learn how
to write classical music for movies
learn how to do remixes learn how to do
music for video games and if you
diversify and you're capable of doing
all these different things you can
actually have a very stable good living
as a musician yet so that would be my
advice to anybody is the more you can do
the better the chances that you're going
to go on and you know be able to prosper
even if one aspect of the music business
completely falls apart it seems like for
young musicians to get their foot in the
door in the industry
it depends what type of musician they
are and what they're ultimately gunning
for you know if you're a 19 year old
aspiring Justin Timberlake where you
want to be a huge pop star then you get
a high-powered music lawyer you have a
million dollar deal with Sony or BMG or
whomever and you do everything you work
with all the hot producers and you come
up with a record that sounds like
everything else on the radio so that's
one route which is tried and true and
not very interesting if you ask me the
other route is to do as much as you can
yourself you know to be a band living in
LA or New York or Minneapolis or Seattle
or wherever and writing great songs and
producing your own music and having a
myspace site and a Facebook site and I
like site where you can actually get
your music in front of people and then
because that dialectic that exists
between the musician and the audience
you put up a piece of music and if it's
a good piece of music the audience
responds
and or if it's a bad piece of music they
tell you why they think it's bad and
hopefully you can learn from that and I
think it ends up the musicians end up
being able to craft better music because
of that sort of like instantaneous
toilet